After being gone for a week,
my husband's on a six hour flight back home,
and what better way to surprise him
than with some fresh vanilla ice cream
and some gooey chocolate brownies?
I started making my custard for my ice cream
with some milk,
vanilla, sugar,
and some eggs.
Combined my egg yolks with my sugar
and then slowly put some of the warm milk in there
just to get it warm
and then added it to the rest of my milk.
Strained all the vanilla out
and then let it come down to room temperature
before transferring it over to the fridge.
In the meantime,
I started on my brownie batter,
mixed all of my dry ingredients,
and then added my wet ones,
which were some eggs,
some oil, and some water.
I then combined that mixture with my dry ingredients,
gave it a really good mix,
and then transfer that over to my loaf pan
before putting that in the oven.
Then I pulled out my custard and churned it.
When I hit the consistency of soft serve,
I transferred it over to a separate container
to pop it in the freezer for a couple hours.
At this point
my brownie was good to go,
so I pulled it out of the oven
and let it cool completely,
and then my husband walked through the door,
so I decided to serve him up some of that brownie
and ice cream.
This is one of his favorite Sweet treats.
So I'm excited that he really liked it.